The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi I'm Jocelyn and we're going
to go over fall 2009, the
final exam, problem number 6.
It says, the dipeptide shown
below is derived from alanine
and serine.
And I'll write up that
structure here.
And we know it's a dipeptide
because we
see that it has two--
what look like--
amine groups and two kind
of carboxyl groups.
So that's an indicator that
we're dealing with a dipeptide
not just one amino acid.
Something to notice right off
the bat is that we're given
the zwitterion form.
We have the amine group at the
end here is protonated and the
carboxylic group on the other
end is deprotonated.
So moving to part 1.
It asked us to indicate the
position of the peptide bond.
Hopefully this is a pretty
straightforward task.
We realize that the
dipeptide bond is
what makes the dipeptide.
It's the bond between the amine
group of one amino acid
and the carboxyl group
of another.
Right there.
So circling that carbon nitrogen
bond would get you
full credit on that part.
Moving to part 2.
We are asked to draw the
skeletal structure of each
constituent amino acid as it
would be present in an aqueous
solution of an extreme
basicity, i.e. pH
greater than 12.
So before even starting to write
we want to think about
what extreme basicity means.
Well it means that both our
amine group and our carboxylic
acid group are going
to be deprotonated.
So let's start with
alanine first. We
have the central carbon.
The amine group.
And the carboxylic acid group.
Now I just drew that
totally protonated.
However we want to draw it
totally deprotonated because
it's in basic solution.
So I'm just going to erase
the extra hydrogens.
And we have a deprotonated amine
group and a deprotonated
carboxyl group.
And that is what it would look
like in basic solution.
Now serine is a little different
because you have a
side group with functionality.
It has not just carbon
and hydrogen.
First drawing up the backbone
here, we have a central
carbon, which has a methyl
alcohol group off of it.
And attach the carboxylic
acid.
And amine group on
the left here.
So this one I drew as the
zwitterion, which would be in
moderately or kind of neutral.
It depends upon the
amino acid.
But again we want to deprotonate
our amine group
here because pH greater than 12
will not have a protonated
amine group.
Now the question is,
what do we do with
the side chain here?
It has an H attached
to an oxygen.
Does that come off in super
basic solution or not?
A lot of students got
tripped up on this.
An alcohol actually has
a pKa of about 16.
And so it won't be deprotonated
in an aqueous solution.
Therefore we want to keep
this hydrogen on.
It will not be--
this will not be a charged
oxygen in the basic solution
that we were asked about.
So now we are going to
move on to the second
part of this problem.
The second part asks us about
the tertiary structure of the
length of protein
that is shown.
I am not going to draw the whole
length of protein but
we're going to--
at the four specified
locations--
we're going to indicate what
we would call the tertiary
structure; or what functionality
is causing the
tertiary structure.
So looking at that
protein chain.
Professor Sadoway has indicated
four different
distinct parts of the chain.
And the question is asking us,
at each of the four numbered
positions name one chemical
change to the environment of
the protein that would
destabilize the associated
feature in the tertiary
structure.
Explain the relevant chemistry
so it's asking us to say what
can we do to disrupt that
tertiary structure?
And the first thing we need to
do is figure out what the
tertiary structure is.
So if we look at number 1, we
see that it has two sulphur
atoms connected together.
So we call that a
disulfide bond.
The second part, we see that we
have a phenyl group, so it
has a very electron-deficient
hydrogen interacting with a
deprotonated carboxyl
oxygen anion.
And so we have a hydrogen bond
there and that's what's
causing those amino acids
to be pulled together.
So let's just say
hydrogen bond.
At the third number we see
that we had a deprotonate
carboxyl group and a protonated
amine group
interacting.
And that's not quite a hydrogen
bond but it's a
negatively charged part of the
molecule interacting with the
positively charged part of
a different molecule.
And so we call that
electrostatic interaction.
It's similar to a hydrogen
bond in that it's a
intermolecular interaction
that's causing these molecules
to move closer, preference
to be closer together.
And now we come to
the fourth part.
Which is hydrophobic
interactions.
So we see that there
are a lot of just
carbon hydrogen chains.
No oxygen is around, no
amine groups around.
Purely carbon and hydrogen.
And because this is an aqueous
solution, those hydrophobic
parts of the molecules will
preferentially go together and
kind of make a little--
almost like an-- oil
droplet in water.
They're trying to decrease the
amount that they experience
the polarity of the water.
And so the interactions
are hydrophobic.
So now that we know what the
functionality at each of these
points in the DNA structure are,
we can go back to what
the question is actually asking
us, which is, how can
we actually disrupt
these features.
So the first one is the
disulfide bond.
And in class Professor Sadoway
talked about how to disrupt
the disulfide bond.
And one of the ways
is to put extreme
heat on to the protein.
And that breaks the disulfide
bond and you can straighten
out that portion of the DNA.
This is how you straighten your
hair if it's curly or
other types of things with
the disulfide bond.
So heating the disulfide bond to
extreme heat will cause it
to break and thus the protein
will lose that, that folding
or whatever the disulfide bond
imparted to that portion of
the protein.
Now going on to number 2.
We have hydrogen bonding.
And we see that it's between a
alcohol group on a ring there
and a carboxyl group.
So one way to disrupt that
hydrogen bond is to make the
carboxyl group no longer
deprotonated.
So if we put back on the
hydrogen to that oxygen it
will become less partially
negative.
It will have a lower
interaction with that hydrogen.
And so we can say, to protonate
that carboxyl we
want to make the solution
more acidic.
So we can add acid.
So the disulfide we're going
to heat, the hydrogen bond
we're going to add acid.
Looking at number 3 we
see that we have a
electrostatic reaction.
And so we want to not have that
And one way to do that is to
make one of those entities not
have a charge.
So one way to do that would be
to reprotonate the carboxylic
acid, just as we did in
the previous step.
Or we could deprotonate
the amine group.
And that would cause it to lose
its charge and thus the
electrostatic interaction
would be weaker or gone.
So to deprotonate the amine
group we should know that we
want to add base.
And the final part is, the
portion with hydrophilic
interactions.
And here we want to figure
out a way to make those
hydrophobic portions of the
amino acids not hold as
tightly together.
And one thing we learned
about in class is
something like soap.
Something that has a hydrophobic
side and a
hydrophilic side.
And so if we put soap in with
this protein it can kind of
stabilize the hydrophobic part
and make it stretch out a
little bit more, not
ball up so tightly.
So soap or detergent would be
a good answer for this one.
And so for this question, as
long as you indicated the
relevant chemistry, which is
specified what tertiary
structure you were looking
at and how your suggested
procedure would disrupt that
tertiary structure, that's
what Professor Sadoway was
looking for and that would
mean that you answered the
question completely.